flex
et demi point
[Musique]
l'autre pied aujourd'hui comme souvent
ce cours de danse classique haas ancien
l'école est bien remplie dans le
complexe sportif pierre mazeaud une
vingtaine de danseuses s'essaye aux
cabrioles au pas chasser ou encore aux
changements pied une véritable passion
pour ces sportives c'est sympa et
c'est une bonne occupation cup en plus
je vois mes copines préféré s'y colle du
fait
des grands gestes comme ça vous allez
trouver nos conventions classiques et
quand j'ai commencé il y avait déjà mes
amis et tous annulés suis dit que ça
pourrait être cool et j'ai continué
à écrire
regarder la télé en france on compte
près de 80 mille adhérents dont
plusieurs milliers dans les yvelines des
chiffres en augmentation depuis
plusieurs années dans cette structure de
saint cyr l'école créée en 2015 les
inscriptions doublé en six ans pour
passer à 150 adhérents sur la danse
classique la rigueur de la matière leur
plaît beaucoup
l'expérience scénique également on
apprend deux choses essentiellement un
travail purement techniques que vous
avez pu voir par exemple un travail
deux positions deux jambes deux bras et
un travail artistique où on a beaucoup
d'imaginaire et d'expression qui est mis
en jeu dans le travail chorégraphique un
apprentissage qui commence dès le plus
jeune âge ici à saint cyr l'école on
peut débuter à des trois ans
[Musique]